so i'm freaking out a little bit because
today addison is going to
teach me a tick-tock dance try to push
down as far as you can okay yeah
what you better work kimberly i can't
get down like you
addison ray is back on keeping up with
the kardashians and this time
she's teaching kim a tick-tock dance we
should stretch a little before
stretch okay we're gonna do a um
a split so i've never done a split
really oh should should that be a 40
year old goal
yes and while we know addison is a pro
kim seems to be struggling with her
dancing
i have eyes like i see i'm not the best
at it
but i am gonna you know soak this all in
take it home and see if i have it in me
to really do this
it is really intimidating kim also seems
to feel a bit uncomfortable
with some of the sexier moves listen i'm
no dancer
i'm not claiming to be but if anyone's
going to make me look good it's addison
so i'm going to take the time and
practice this and see what i can do
so you're going to start off with a
right leg kick so you'll just kick up
you don't have to go that high but like
yeah yeah which arm so left arm yeah and
then you're going to turn to the side
on your hands and knees oh god it's like
super
hoey i wanted to be more we know from
instagram that kim's dance lesson is for
a skims tick tock she's hoping to make
how cute would it be hear me out
let's hear it if i shot a skim's
campaign in tiktok but where it's
me and different outfits just doing
dances yeah
no you should definitely do that
and remember addison has actually
modeled for skims
addison you posted i think you're part
of kim kardashian skim's one year
anniversary campaign
yeah i am which has been incredible and
super exciting and
um when i got presented the opportunity
i was so grateful and so blessed and
it's kind of something that was
different than
i normally would do um and a little bit
like out of my comfort zone
for you know where i am but it was so
exciting and so fun and
um definitely an opportunity i'm glad i
didn't miss the entire thing is just so
crazy to me because it's like it
happened so fast that i'm like
i like don't have a really like a minute
to process everything at once so like
when i do it like all hits me at once
and i'm like what's going on here like
what is my life
addison has been spending tons of time
with the kardashians
it all blossomed from her friendship
with courtney she's been a great
person to have in my life and i think
she has great energy as well and she has
so much experience in her life that i
can really just look at and
kind of learn from but we just learned
on keeping up that courtney sisters
initially questioned their friendship
remember courtney is 22 years older than
addison
what the [ __ ] do you do to courtney to
make her so happy honestly
at the beginning we were like wait are
they
i'm still thinking that hooking up
if it was like that kind of relationship
that was the elephant in the room
no we're not last year addison talked to
e.t
about the age gap between her and
courtney
a lot of people have judged your
relationship with courtney just because
of the age gap
what do you have to say to those people
um i think that
at the end of the day i think
friendships are
kind of just i mean what you make them
and what you have like the time you
spend with them the things you
enjoy doing and if you have things in
common um it kind of just makes sense
and i don't think that's anything to
really judge people on i feel like
friendships can range from any age
[Music]